not long ago David Letterman offered
this sweeping and straightforward theory
of the cinema every movie he said would
be better with Tom Hanks in it it is a
wonderful remark and one that contains
two great realities the first is that
film starring Tom Hanks have been some
of the most successful and most
important films of the past 25 years and
the second is that Tom Hanks
extraordinary acting ability and
universal appeal actually make it seem
perfectly plausible to cast him in every
movie it's impossible for me to condense
the career of Tom Hanks into an
introduction of reasonable length but in
fact his vast popularity makes such an
introduction unnecessary let me list
just a selection of his roles while you
recall them in your own minds mermaid
infatuated Allen Bauer in splash
thirteen-year-old Josh Baskin trapped in
a man's body and big baseball has been
in manager Jimmy Dugan and a league of
their own the noble and ennobling Andrew
Beckett in Philadelphia Forrest Gump
woody in the to toy stories jim lovell
at Apollo 13 captain John Miller and
save at Saving Private Ryan death row
guard Paul Edgecomb in The Green Mile
maroon Chuck Noland in castaway hit ban
Michael Sullivan in Road to Perdition
the guy who gets meg Ryan in Joe versus
the volcano and again in Sleepless in
Seattle and once more and you've got
mail and in the Polar Express he played
almost everybody including Santa Claus
so I'm introducing quite a few people
today this list is of course incomplete
especially for those who've told me
you've seen everything our speaker has
ever done including all episodes of
those and buddies but the list not only
highlights the prominence of his films
but also illustrates his impressive
range of comedic and dramatic roles
playing both good guys and bad guys
although never so good that we lose
interest and never so bad that we fail
to relate and even identify let me add
to the list the two HBO miniseries from
the earth to the moon and Band of
Brothers not only because they represent
Tom Hanks remarkable work as a writer
director and producer
they also illustrate the depths of his
knowledge and his continuing a passion
and appreciation for two great human
dramas of the American 20th century the
space program and a heroism and
sacrifice of soldiers in world war ii by
virtually any measure Tom Hanks is
America's leading film actor his awards
include five Best Actor Academy Award
nominations with back-to-back Oscars for
Philadelphia and Forrest Gump
four Golden Globe Awards and three Emmys
in 2002 he was the youngest ever
recipient of the American Film
Institute's Lifetime Achievement Award
and in the current Harris Poll of
favorite movie stars he's number one
along both women and men the path to
these Heights was far from direct by the
age of 10 he had in his own words
three mothers five grammar schools and
ten houses finally staying put in
Oakland California for junior high
school and high school he caught the
acting bug and in the summer after his
junior in college was performing with
the Great Lakes Shakespeare Festival in
Cleveland the intervening years of
uncertainty in the breakthroughs of
Bosom Buddies and big included for Tom
and his first wife Susan Dillingham the
birth of a son Colin and then of a
daughter Elizabeth
happily for Vassar one of our graduates
today as all of you are aware the bond
that forms between Vassar and her
graduates extends to whole families and
the Hanks family is no exception in
addition to private visits to see Liz
Tom Hanks has become a part of that
larger Vassar family in other ways most
notably in his participation and one of
the most literally stellar events
celebrating our new center for drama and
film last fall when I extended the
invitation today's speaker I told him
that he along with every parent at
today's ceremony would be cast in a role
in support of the starring roles of
their sons and daughters but his
supporting role might be just a little
more demanding I was thrilled and
delighted when he accepted like any
movie a Vassar commencement is better
with Tom Hanks in it it's my great
pleasure to introduce to you Tom Hanks
thank you
Thank You Fran for that introduction as
Milton's wife said to Milton of Milton's
Paradise Lost it seems a little long to
me but I liked it not long ago I was
reading about the problem of gridlock on
the freeways of Southern California the
traffic jams which crippled the city
stranding millions in laying waste to
time and energy and the environment
gridlock is as serious and as
impenetrable a problem as any we face a
dilemma without cure without solution
like everything else in the world it
seems some smart folks concocted a
computer simulation of gridlock to
determine how many cars should be taken
off the road to turn a completely jammed
and steel highway into a free-flowing
one
how many cars must be removed from that
commute until a 20 mile drive takes 25
minutes instead of two hours the results
were startling
four cars
needed to be removed from that virtually
stuck highway to free up that simulated
commute for cars out of each 100 cars
for cars per 100 cars for autos out of
every 100 autos
the 40 cars from each thousand 400 out
of 10,000 for cars out of 100 are not
that many to cars out of every 50 one
driver out of every 25 drivers now if
this said if the simulation is correct
it is the most dramatic definition in
earthly science and human nature of how
a simple choice will make a jaw-dropping
difference to our world call it the
power of for one commuter in your
neighborhood could put the rush back
into rush hour so if merely for people
out of a hundred can make gridlock go
away by choosing not to use their car
imagine the other changes that can be
wrought by just four of us four of you
out of a hundred take a hundred
musicians in a depressed port city in
northern England choose John Paul George
and Ringo
you have a Jew
take a hundred computer geeks in Redmond
Washington said 96 of them home the
remainder is called Microsoft take the
power of four and apply it to any and
every area of your concern
politics for votes swung from one
hundred into another hundred is the
difference between gaining control and
losing clout culture - ticket buyers out
of 50 can make a small odd film
profitable economics by boycotting a
product one consumer out of 25 can move
that product to the back of the shelf
and eventually off it all together four
out of 100 is miniscule and yet can be
the great lever of the tipping point the
power of four is the difference between
helplessness and help h e LP a
four-letter word
like some others with many meanings the
graduating class of 2005 can claim with
perhaps more credibility than any other
class in history that during its four
years of college the world went crazy in
the fall of 2001 our planet Earth in the
United States of America were different
sorts of places in tone and tolerance in
peace and war and ideas and in ideals
than they are on this spring day in 2005
these past years have been extraordinary
the express rate of change well beyond
the usual standards of culture and well
above the personal watermarks you have
stamped as college students as college
graduates you now live in a brand-new
world with new versions of political
upheaval global pandemic world war and
religious polarization the likes of
which have rarely visited our planet all
at once and thank God for that today's
main purpose is to celebrate your
entering into society but the fact is
you have all been very much steeped in
it already
Poughkeepsie being the proxy and
microcosm of the whole wide world none
of you were untouched by the events in
September of your freshman year none
unaffected by the ideological movements
of local and geopolitics sense all of
you have been staring your individual
fate and our collective future right in
the eye for the last four years the
common stereotype would have you today
cap in the air parchment in hand asking
yourself what do I do now you the class
of 2005 had already had many many
moments during your time at Vassar when
you ask yourself that question you might
have added the word hell to some such
four-letter words to that phrase what
the hell do I do now in which case today
might not be all that different from
other day
on campus except your parents are here
they might take you out for better food
on commencement day speech makers are
expected to offer advice as though you
need any as though anything said today
could aid your making sense of our one
damn thing after another world but
things are too confused too loud too
dangerous to make advice an option you
need to hear something much more
relevant on this day you need to hear
the most important message thus far in
the third millennium you need to hear a
maxim so simple so clear and so
evocative that no one could misconstrue
its meaning or miss its weighty issue so
here goes it's not a statement it's but
it's a request it's not a bit of advice
but it's a plea in fact it's a single
four-letter word it's a verb and a noun
which takes into account the reality of
your four years advance or as demands of
the next four decades you spend beyond
this campus it's a message once made
familiar by the Beatles those northern
English lads who embodied the power of
four
help
we need help your help you must help
please help please provide help please
be willing to help help and you will
make a huge impact on the life of the
street to town the country and our
planet if only one out of four of each
hundred of you choose to help on any
given day in any given cause incredible
things will happen in the world you live
in
help publicly help privately help in
your actions by recycling and conserving
and protecting but help also in your
attitude help make sense where sense has
gone missing help bring a reason and
respect to discourse and debate help
science to solve and faith to soothe
help law bring justice until justice is
commonplace help and you will abolish
apathy the void which is so quickly
filled by ignorance and evil life
outside of college is just like life in
it one nutty thing after another
some of them horrible but all
interspersed with enough beauty and
goodness to keep you going that's your
job to keep going your duty is to help
without ceasing the art you create can
glorify it the science you pursue can
prove its value the law you practice can
pass on it
benefits the faith you embrace will make
it the earthly manifestation of your God
here at Vassar whatever your discipline
whatever your passion you have already
experienced the exhausting reality that
there is always something going on and
there is always something to do and most
assuredly you have sensed how effective
and empowering it can be when more than
four out of 100 make the same choice to
help you will always be able to help so
do it
make peace where it is precious help
plant trees help embrace diversity and
celebrate differences help stop gridlock
in other words help solve every problem
we face every single one of them with
the power of four out of a hundred help
and we will save the world if we don't
help it won't get done congratulations
good luck and thank you